[Music]
I'm curious where do you consider
yourself politically is there a label
that you like as I sent sort of a
classical liberalism here but maybe
something a little more closer to a
traditional Democrat I'm not yeah you
know I told you earlier on on the phone
I'm not really politically that astute I
just have these feelings that align me
with the left so I've always very
democratic my whole life
and I consider myself a liberal but what
a liberal means now as you know is
changing a lot of people consider
themselves liberals who are actually a
liberal oh yeah
the regressive or a liberal Lefton I
don't align myself with those groups at
all yeah you know and in your world in
the science world you have to deal with
facts you can't deal with these feelings
all the time so that that illiberal left
misguide you completely crazy I know it
does because I've read plenty of your
writings yeah I mean in science the one
thing that freedom of speech is
absolutely essential in science then
just this moment I realize that that may
be why I'm such a free speech advocate
or yourself or you allow yourself to be
censored in science you're you're doing
something really bad I mean the freedom
of discourse the freedom to criticize
somebody no matter how ill-founded
you are you think there is the absolute
cynic went on for scientific progress
and when you see this happening in
science that some I I mean outside of
science so some ideas are off limits
that you can't talk about them so like
what like what for example like I'll be
something that's off limits like oh
what's happened to my leg innopolis for
example I mean I just read this morning
that he had been booted off you see
there's campus because you know I know
he's had Milo in your show he's coming
back in two weeks yeah you everything
you know um he's a bit of a rocket or I
don't know if everything he says he
really believes I mean he's made
statements like there's no such thing as
a lesbian yeah I don't really think that
sure I think he says that to get people
standing up on the other hand he has
said stuff that should be said because
it starts a conversation so sorry like
do we have a rape culture in the United
States I mean and you know a lot of
radical feminists will though if you
deny that they'll just jump down your
throat
tell you a misogynist but what you know
what is the rig closer so the closer
actually condones right we don't live in
accident we don't live in that culture
is it enclosure where if you're a
convicted rapist you get off more easily
than if you committed some of the crime
I don't think so
certainly every rape is one rate too
many and they should be punished to the
limit of Allah but to say something like
that and that's the kind of thing that
Milo's says which actually should be
discussed we need this kind of stuff to
discussion but there are certain things
now other things that cannot be
questioned like affirmative action I'm
in favor affirmative action but you know
you cannot question it but it's almost
impossible to have an honest discussion
yeah and how do the economics work in
actually is it helping people yeah and
all of those things so what about in the
scientific realm that's what I
originally meant in the scientific realm
are there places that you sometimes want
to go that are shunned on oh absolutely
yeah like what looking well it's uh give
you two examples the first one is the
concept of race okay I mean these both
these examples the other one is
evolutionary psychology are valid areas
of inquiry and in science but ones which
have ideological repercussions for a
group of people so for example you
cannot say that there are human races
because it makes people say well you're
just enabling racism if you say that
right and now what you're saying that
there are we well no I mean there's a
really really specific because the human
species is not distributed into a finite
number of easily distinguishable genetic
groups but what happens is that if you
can take a person's genome and
sequencing you can pretty much place
where they came from so there are in the
aggregate check differences between
groups now they're not large because
we've all come out of Africa about
60,000 years because it has a big time
for this wholesale accumulation of
differences but they're nevertheless
there are differences and you can use
statistical measures to show that they
form roughly five or six different
groups that are distributed
geographically as as you might say you
know there's the New World groups
there's Asian groups there's Polynesians
there's Africans and each of these
groups was geographically separated at
one time from other groups so you expect
them
become different but you know you can't
really even say that right because it
implies that that there's a scale of
inferior Aryan superiority right so
sometimes people will say to me I see
this on Twitter a certain amount you
know you're focusing too much on the
political correctness are you focusing
too much on the free speech stuff but
you're giving me a great real world
scientific example of why it's important
right I mean that's that's really to be
able to talk about this stuff for you as
a scientist it is important but do you
think a lot of times its self select out
of that me I can even deal with it
absolutely I mean the whole field of
cultural anthropology is dedicated to
verifying those people that even want to
study giant differences between humans
and then they look at that guy and they
go well why would he want to do that he
must somehow be racist oh yeah why we
even look at that yeah when I write
about race and I try to avoid using the
word race just because it's the
hot-button issue I'll say ethnic groups
or jjang differences you know and if
you'll talk to the image Genesis that
working us you'll see of course humans
are genetically differentiated we're a
species like any other where ample suck
and we're spread over a huge area so
there's going to be differences that are
accumulated by evolutionary processes
like selection and drift but you can't
say that and so duplicate race is a
social construct right and I don't know
what the hell that means I mean if
there's a social construct and somebody
like Rachel Dolezal can designate
herself as black even though she's not
black right any means for some reason I
don't like that yeah what's up so that's
one area in which research is basically
tableau Steve Penner I think has spent a
lot of his career trying to to overcome
these taboos in science I mean it does
not necessarily mean that if you're
studying generation and image you're
racist most people aren't they're just
fascinated with the history of and you
know by studying this racial we've
learned things about how humans have
migrated we know now that we came to
North America and South America over the
Bering Straits about 15,000 years ago
from genetic evidence I mean we can use
our genes to trace our migration
patterns we know that we made it within
the inner soles right you know probably
oh god I don't know of 6070 thousand
years ago that's fast
doesn't have many practical implications
but you know a lot of evolutionary
biology is like lawrence krauss said
it's knowledge it's art it's fascinating
it doesn't necessarily have to make you
rich or wealthy we and the only reason
we know all this stuff about humans is
because humans are genetically different
in different places we wouldn't be able
to trace their migration you wouldn't be
able to trace your ancestry by sending
in a kit to 23andme if humans did not
have these genetic differences right so
but to talk about them is almost a
terribly the other example which God's
pod talked about two days ago was
evolutionary psychology the idea that we
bear in our behaviors and in our body's
remnants of evolutionary processes that
occur in our ancestors that's taboo so
okay so I've talked about this with dad
a little bit I'm still struggling to
understand what's the tableau part why
would that be what's the part of that
that people struggle with well it the
main area besides the race thing because
the well when we back up the main thing
is males the difference between males
and females evolution actually calls you
because that's what that's what
evolutionary psychology is by and large
concentrate on although there are other
things as well and they think just as
the cultural anthropologists say that
you're you're a racist if you're staying
racist if you're studying evolutionary
differences and say mating behavior
between males and females you must be a
success patient which of course is
absolutely insane well is right now just
like they say races are social
constructs yeah and I got to say I got
to add one thing here which always
amused me when I was writing my NIH
grants to get my funding from a research
that asks you what your ethnicity what
your race was you had to take off a box
like you know a Inuit South Pacific
Islander white black Hispanic and then
at the bottom of the box that said no
these these classifications or social
constructs only and and yet I was
writing you know a genetic grant Soleri
yeah well you should use what why are
you asking me that yeah I wouldn't get a
grant yeah so the man right the main
thing is is is the that people think
that evolutionary psychology
is a vehicle for enabling sexism you
know my a response to that is always
this to point out that males are bigger
and more muscular than females and
that's it's definitely a genetic
difference and it's the same in
virtually every other species of primate
with very few exceptions and we know why
it is it's because males compete with
each other for access for females is
very good evolutionary theory and that's
exactly what you expect
we have huge difference in upper body
strength mega strategies are so clearly
different between males and females
males are fairly promiscuous females are
choosy just like there are another
animals so we have this confluence of
lines of evidence that point to this
most obvious difference between men and
women and body size as a result of what
happened in our ancestor so that
basically all goes back to just
hunter-gatherer stuff right that the man
was out there hunting in the woman well
that's one theory about why men are
struggling that women had to stay home
and reproduce and the men would have to
be stronger but there's a number of
things that don't but that doesn't
explain like the difference in choosing
this between males and females so I mean
the theory wishes superb I a lot of
evidence is that the difference in body
size team men and women is an
evolutionary result of males competing
for for females and females in rings
well they would want the men that could
hunt the best but they also want them
and we'd have the best genes but the
fact is that here's the difference that
is not is not cultural you cannot say
that you know men and women are
socialized men are socialized to be
perfectly right
it just doesn't work that way and so if
we can evolve these differences and
there may be some truth to what you say
about the hunter-gatherer saying but
that still shows that there's an
evolutionary basis for the body size
differences we see the average man I
think in America's v can the average
woman I think is 5 4 that's pretty kind
of difference in the body so now you're
gonna be a height is 2 you're really
yeah but so you know if there's such a
profound difference in body size that's
the result of evolutionary forces
why are we so resistant to thinking that
there's evolutionary differences in
behavior yeah so when did that happen
when did this this political crisis when
did a creep and decides I mean 50 years
ago if we were talking about this kind
of stuff would it be more
okay to talk about in fact it was
Donnelly okay it was de rigueur but it
was too far the other way because people
would would make flat statements like
there's a hierarchy of races and the
whites are on top and the blacks on the
bottom and clearly in total we don't
have any evidence for that so if you
look at the textbooks and evolution from
the 20s you'll see this kind of
invidious racism it was widely accepted
so some of the political correctness
maybe a reaction to it because they
always point back and say look this is
what biology gave us in the 1920s every
evolutionist was promulgating the view
the whites are superior and by and large
that was true wait what would she do
that they were doing now advisers not
their white peers you know they were
probably getting the ideas pushing the
idea with no evidence at all that went
to some pretty horrible shaky there
because that's where people would cut
the quote and go you see what he just
said oh yeah they let me say vector that
that there are no evidence there is no
Evan yeah
so that Avot well just were pretty
invidious racist as a whole I mean along
with the rest of society back in the
1920s I mean well just just had another
way of rationalized but they were wrong
and so some of the political correctness
is a reaction to this this over this
file is just going overboard and
biological determinism but there's a
middle ground in which there are valid
things to study and God thought is one
of the guys that studies them about
human behavior and it's evolutionary
antecedents but they'll say gender is a
social construct I mean you know if you
look at humanity you know 99% of people
will fall into the two tails of has a
white chromosome
identifies as male likes women two
x-chromosomes that I don't write is
female likes men and then you know
there'll be some inter sexes in between
but to say that it's gender social
construct is is to me just completely
fresh if that's yeah I mean it just
doesn't make any sense
let's circle back a little bit to
evolution sure so we're just on this
road now and we're evolving very slowly
at you know in the day to day we're
evolving where does technology start
coming into this because now we're we're
we are going to eventually you know you
talked about like singularity and just
how science is going to change it and
we're going to start putting on you know
robotic arms and robotic limbs and I
don't let can that be thought of as the
next step of evolution if you're taking
something that's totally artificial and
adding it to the well start over with
you
yeah they require something else well
there's two questions in there and I'll
try to answer both them first of all
remember the definition of evolution
give you which is change in populations
so if you give somebody an artificial
artificial hand you're not changing the
genetic nice to population what you're
doing maybe compensating for certain
genetic defects and so one of the
results of medical intervention is that
we have people living today who would
not be surviving on the savanna yeah I
look at the lifespan of individuals in
art and Australopithecus it was probably
25 30 years max and now there's science
we have you know the average lifespan
are probably 70 to 80 years in humans
and that's the result of science but
it's not a result of genetic changes at
all right well it's a medical
intervention so what's happened is
people that would have been cold and our
ancestors are now leaving their genes
behind so is the gene pool degenerating
yet to some extent it is I mean look at
me I have you know a myopic you know I
have you know crowns up some of my teeth
I probably would have had an abscess I
mean restorations pointed out to
probably a major cause of death our
ancestors tooth abscess yeah sure enough
so to some extent this medical
intervention is causing evolution but
it's causing evolution to go downhill in
other words the gene pool is
degenerating very slowly right I'm very
slow but and but I would ask people to
worry about this you know okay do you
want to kill those people it would if
somebody has an infection you want to
withhold antibiotics from them and let
them go and nobody would say yes so that
so you know the slug degeneration of the
gene pool caused by medical intervention
which is evolution is to me far
outweighed by the fact that people live
longer healthier lives than they have
before so I'm not worried about that
right so I guess my question then is
although it's not evolution in the
traditional sense I'm a
sighs bye guys I can show every week and
that it seems to me that as time is
going to go by in a couple more decades
we're going to slowly replace our part
we're going to slowly replace our
organic stuff with artificial stuff so
we'd be evolving into something else but
I guess not in the technical term yeah
what you that would be cultural of yeah
more or less cultural juncture is
offensive to someone somehow or
something yeah so that's what's going to
have it I mean the question I get more
frequently from people is well are we
still evolving technically as a species
and that's a tough question because how
do we know that you know we have to be
able to see and you know it's a slow
process we have to be able to see how
people change and connect that with
their reproductive advantage because
evolution occurs by certain people
leaving more genes than others that have
certain traits and so when people ask me
this question and they invariably do
when I give a public lecture where are
we going evolutionarily are we getting
smarter were we getting handsomer
you know and my answer is well here's
what we know about where we're evolving
women are arriving at menopause later
they're because they're starting to
menstruate earlier and we are resistant
to heart attacks is going up and that's
about all we know it's not very excited
at alive well you know that you know
this from from like the Framingham
Health say whether it will follow of
individuals and their offspring and so
we'll know you know the Genet first of
all don't know the correlation between
parent offspring which gives you an idea
of genetics and also the number of
offspring that parents have which give
you an idea of how that Jax is connected
to reproduction which gives you an idea
of how natural selection is working so
what's happening is that women are
evolving to be remain fertile longer
they're coming in to fertility condition
earlier Europeans are getting taller a
little bit and heart disease is so we
are evolving and we're always going to
evolve as long as we have genetic
variation sources of mortality that will
kill us before we stop reproducing right
so could we have another one of those
splits that you talked about it's a you
know 20 years from now we've got a
colony on Mars so you have a separate
subset of people and that they start
reproducing
and there's different you know physical
pressures on them with gravity and all
of these things could they like I
suppose they would evolve differently
than us but it could happen kind of
quicker right because because they'd be
sort of the raw stuff there yeah well
and it depends on first of all if they'd
have to be allowed to have children and
they'd have to be for good and they'd
have to be isolated from Earth so if you
read of the colony out of Mars if you
keep a let's go with that we said it not
we send one hundred people and we leave
them out are we leaving out there yeah
there are all of this thing forever then
it is I would certainly not say it's
impossible for them to become in
different species of human what I would
say is that you have to prevent
migration back and forth because that's
going to bring them closer together and
what we need is for them to divert
genetically to become different species
yeah but it would take maybe a million
years to see any change now you can see
some change very quickly I mean you know
they're you know as long as there is
differential reproduction based on you
know maybe weightlessness people that
kind of depth of weightlessness better
would leave more offspring on Mars and
and you might see some change pretty
quickly but you have to have enough
change that if you bring these people
from Mars back to earth or you send
people from earth back to Mars they
would be unable to produce fertile
offspring where I can't just be slight
differences in the way they look like a
very real definition it yes there have
some or they would they be so
unrecognizably different to each other
they wouldn't want to mate with each
other which is inform what we call
behavioral isolation it's many birds can
produce fertile offspring but they don't
because they don't see each other as
appropriate image so basically they
could over a few generations there could
be some physical changes yeah well we
think of well remember a generation
humans is probably 20 for 30 years now
right so you know what you know it would
take you know maybe a hundred
generations before we see anything
perceptible and that's you know several
thousand years yeah and then to get to
the point where these people become
reflectively incompatible in other words
I would say I mean this is just an
offhand guess tricking other animals a
million years maybe you know and you
know would Ruby still be around them
maybe not but I believe that
yeah it's conceivable there were as I
said in time
in history not Neanderthals and humans
were not different species of the same
species but we had diverged you know in
physical ways and you know brow ridges
and stuff and we had Denisovans and
other kinds of human groups which were
probably the same species but in Africa
there were differently different species
of humans that probably could not
interbreed that lived side by side the
so-called robust australopithecines you
know there could have been as many as
four or five different species of
hominids I won't say humans just
Pomerance things that that branched off
for the chips and and we're part of the
tree that evolved after that living side
by side without mating with one another
and it's kind of and you know there are
some books about this but there should
be more books about this written by
maybe evolutionarily minded science
fiction writers about what it would be
like to have two cerebral eyes bipedal
species meet each other what would
happen if that was the case huh all
right maybe I'll write that book maybe
you may have to be my co-author yes all
right final question I wanted to ask
this right at the top but I feel like
it's a nice way to wrap everything up
when you're in the lab with the
microscope and you're looking at all of
this is that basically your greatest joy
greatest joy
the greatest joy is actually the moment
where after two years of looking through
the microscope you put the data together
and you see what it looks like and then
you see what result you get so you know
it's punctuated joy I mean it's a lot of
fun to do this but you're waiting to
find an answer and those answers don't
come every day as it's coming and
sometimes they just come on your press
the button on a statistics program and
all of a sudden you get what you know in
the same way they found out the Higgs
boson I mean all of a sudden like you
know they have two different groups and
they press a button and they they see
they get the same thing so it's at the
end of that process that you really find
the greatest joy but you know I mean
it's like working on I think of it a lot
of like the people who worked on the
medieval cathedrals you know they knew
when they built lat or no Saddam that
they were not going to see the process
or working
hmm and but they did anyway because they
knew they were working towards some
result well in science we do get our
result in our lifetime it's just that
these moments of ineffable joy of
discovery come very rarely you know and
but that's what we're working to but
it's it all makes it worthwhile in the
long run because without all that hard
work of pushing fuzz under the
microscope for years you don't get to
find out just cool thing at the end yeah
that's a pretty good ending right there
there you go
all right well for more on Jerry's work
check out why evolution is true
wordpress.com I want to pull your
thoughts right hand below
[Music]
you